you know that's one thing I haven't
heard yet today is carbon and soil and
that's the driving force in what we're
doing I don't care what anybody says
that's a driving force and we've got to
really focus on that you know and
another thing I've learned over the
years is you can't make all the mistakes
yourself and I really try to do that so
what I'm saying is team together you
guys with your neighbor or whatever and
try to learn from each other because if
rather we realized or not we have to
change what we're doing we have got to
change what we're doing we've got to be
more sustainable
so we're 9600 acres and we've been
no-till since 1993 we feel like residues
really a friend we'll do our rotation
with a heavier residue crop because we
need the soil armor so residue is our
friend we did not take one if we'd out
of a rotation because residue is our
friend
we've got to have that soil armor Brady
85 hundred acres of grass on the
Missouri River breaks 850 head of cows
at the cow-calf pair and you can see
that'll always be a virgin sod and and
it's a good thing the boys do a really
good job of managing there are pastures
they they rotate them they've got
divided fences they're doing a
tremendously good job with their cattle
and and it's nothing but a where I used
to think it was kind of a detriment to a
farm and now I think it's all about our
farm is about our cattle because one
pays the other one off so here's our
pasture and the bad thing is it's in one
chunk and so when we run into a little
dry spell and we get hurt but then we
run into in the wintertime we've got two
sections where we bring the cows home -
and so we so we had an issue so we're
bringing them home we were grazing them
hard we're losing residue so we were
getting to her
our home two sections we're losing
productivity off of it because we are
grazing it too hard in the winter time
and so then as the story goes along I'll
tell you how we tried to remedy that
okay so I don't know how many you guys
have read Howard Buffett's book 40
chances so what he said in this book is
you've got 40 chances in your life to
make a difference just think about that
your farmer maybe you've already used 20
so you've got 40 chances to really make
a difference in your life
so I've already used 48 let's see what
what I'm ashamed of embarrassed of and
what I'm trying to make better is the
first 24 years I completely destroyed
this soil then what Dave was talking
about in the 70s I lived the 70s I mean
it was I did we did everything we could
do to destroy the soil and we didn't
know any better and I'm not so sure that
isn't what happened right now so much to
do in so little time to me that's my
main goal it's what I want to do is if I
can influence people to do the right
thing that's a win-win situation for me
so in the seventies we were good farmers
we felt we were the better farmers
around
we are cover crops was wild buck what
buckwheat and cosa weed and and though
we didn't really understand anything all
we knew was we were so busy working so
busy no one doing we were doing the
right thing
tilling the ground working the ground
after harvest she would go out there and
you'd you had the power to disc it when
dave said there when you started plough
and you kept plowing and till the color
of the soil changed what we'd do was I
mean actually you guys in the time that
we ploughed we did we were plowing six
inches deep and then all of a sudden you
went to five because we're turning it up
yellow dirt we didn't understand
but so we're our own worst enemies the
worst two pieces of machinery you can
use this one's terrible cuts all the
macropores off we had to go to we had we
finally went to Buckley because earlier
normal blades because our Buckley was so
bad we couldn't get through our stubble
because the buckwheat was so bad right
now we don't have any buckwheat on our
farm with our rotations we pretty well
take care of it so farm in the 80s so
you'd go along and every time the wind
blew if you were in powder if you were
someplace you were afraid to look like
Tosti to be the West because there'd be
dirt in here and we're just so we just
been so afraid it would be us that we
just go home you wouldn't go out look
because it wasn't a lot you could do
about it but we still thought we were
good farmers so we didn't have really
good we didn't really have really good
deals what we thought we thought we did
one thing about the corn this 70 bushel
we'd never plant corn but over three
miles away from the farm because we knew
we were going to have to cut it for
silage we knew it wouldn't make corn so
we'd always be close to the house and
then another thing is this was on black
summer fellow and we thought we were
good farmers so our organic matter
really you know it was going down and
then we started using some fertilizer
and and you talked about a response you
talked about a response first we started
using phosphorus of 50-pound bags and
then we went to some nitrogen and we had
one drill with the with fertilizer rope
or fertilizer cashflow and the other
than we didn't but you talk about a
response so we thought we had this deal
figured out you know I just compared the
rainfall here Alexandr you know they get
about thirty seven where am I at
twenty-four about 25 inches
we get nineteen six only thing is you
guys are a little bit warmer but then
look at this year there's not a lot of
difference is there this isn't all this
is in our whole County but see the thing
like with us you take our snow away and
we have seventeen three inches of
moisture this year and you guys had
eighteen point one so one thing about
this whole thing with this snow were you
able to capture it did you have the
residue standing that you're not using
the knife rollers did you leave that
residue stand to catch that snow a lot
of guys say you're too wet and I think
with the no-till and in a high diversity
and rotation I think you can handle I
make it different so this is part of
County so it's just like anything and
I'm sure it's the same way the county is
here see the difference in the rainfalls
so there's our place there's a main farm
but see there's a river there's our
pastures 13 inches of rain down there
this year I mean so the boys in there
they're the native grass and their
pasture rotations are bringing us
through but it's it's an issue okay this
is how it all changed Duane back you
know I'm very fortunate enough to be on
Dakota lakes board and I'm very
fortunate enough to be on South Dakota
soil health coalition board Dwayne's the
one that started this the only reason
Dwayne we were the first ones in our
area to start a no-till we have seven
50s and we didn't know what we were
doing with Dwayne's lead but I mean you
talk about someone you didn't have
places like this to go to safe what am I
going to do we didn't have we were
really struggling with rotations we we
just it was a struggle but you can't put
a value on what it's done for our area
and when I say no-till I mean low
residue no-till as far as I am concerned
there's a shank drill that will do quite
a bit of damage I'm talking about it
if drill you know there's a lot of
no-till captures carbon and organic
matter which is full of nutrients
so yes the tillage past will release
those nutrients causing a crop response
but then you are back to square one it's
like burning your house your house for
heat you did get some heat but you
destroyed your house so basically you're
not capturing that carbon all the carbon
you plant took in you go work it
whatever the way that carbon goes in the
air there's a lot of truth to that you
guys we have to focus on carbon there's
no question in my mind you have to focus
on carbon so we were looking for ways to
fertilize we had 750 drills and on and
so we tried spreading urea and we really
get like that because we knew were
volatize and we knew where it loses some
fertilizer and you're always you there's
a lot of times they're having to spread
when they had time instead of when it
should have been done so then we went to
anhydrous and you can see why we didn't
like anhydrous see what it did to the
soil anytime you do that you're gonna
release carbon then another thing you're
going to lose that source or armor and
we had to have that soil armor so this
is how we do our wheat and there's a
reason I'm going to tell you on how why
we put our fertilizer down so we have an
1895 drill so the fertilizer will gold
the nitrogen to go five inches away from
the seed and then the but the reason
when you do that when there's five
inches away 45 inches away from the seed
at the fourth week four sleeve the
nitrogen and fertilizer will get
together and when it does that then
that's how you can control your
tillering
so basically what you're doing instead
of like having five pillars if it's
broadcast we want about we want about
two and a half
good heads between two and two and a
half a good hands per kernel of wheat we
don't want to grow strong we want to
grow heads of wheat so that really
helped another thing about the 1895 the
first one that John Deere Bill went to
Ralph Holsworth he's the neighbor he
started no-tilling year before we did it
went to he lives a mile or three miles
west of Weston and drill number two went
to our farm so that's how much we
believe that we're that in this system
and then we'll put down we'll put down
1152 and reduce of potash and AMS with
their starter and the potash we want the
chloride for soil health and then we
come back at stream bar I know Dave said
that with us we have to have protein we
have got to have quality we have to
assure ourselves of quality so what
we'll do is we'll put enough on and then
we'll come back the way the weather is
timing the weather or whatever in heaven
and then we'll come back and stream
barge at about fetus five because in our
environment we have got to have protein
if we do not have protein like on spring
wood if we don't have 14 protein does
it's just about feed they'll cost you a
dollar a bushel so this is our a field
of no tilled
long-term no-till sunflower stalks and
you can see our residue I mean you can't
say enough good things about our residue
but so there's quite a bit of that
around so that was in central South
Dakota in 2007 just a little bit little
what too far from our place that came
off the sunflower field so we got to
stop this we know how to stop this well
here's 2012 that's four miles from my
place that was a bean field that they
planted the spring wheat and then it
blew there's quite a bit of that where
they'll put fertilizer on bean stubble
in the fall and then it'll blow so you
know we got over that we won't let that
happen again whoops we did you know
that's organic matter there this is a
this is a high note Hill environment
that's what manage you'll do man
but we'll do we've got to pay attention
to that everybody's got to pay attention
that we can't let that happen
so you know and this is Dwayne helped us
with this week so what do we do so
here's an 1895 drill these are 10 inches
apart so and then so all we did and this
isn't a very good picture but see we
just took and put the wheel over here
will over there so then you've got a
rolling stock standing right here we did
it we did that on both sides of the
drill on the wings and that was enough
so what our fields look right now that's
what I feel look like and that was
enough to stop to blowing if you if we
have enough residue we won't blow but
that's enough to stop the blowing so our
row crowd fertilizers will we put we on
the river we do a little different but
on our dryland are your real gold three
inches off the side and two inches down
and we'll put our starter with with the
the seed and I'm gonna there's I'm
coming too that's why we're doing this
so if you broadcast urea on top to soil
the rias enzyme will break it down and
that's where you get it we release it
and get your validation so but if it's
under the ground it'll help but he'll
slow it down so this is my theory and
it's just a theory so Colton and you can
google it this was in the thrill
magazine I've read quite a bit about
this so what they claim is you if you
pack it if you pack that urea into tight
deal it'll it'll slow down your real
system and make it flow relief and I
really I really feel that's working for
so you say what's your benefit abandon
someone will say well you can cut back
some will say well you know cuz it's
close to the seed and I you know and
this is my thought now get into a little
more what
ah hi I'm beginning to believe this all
the time a lot of you guys have probably
read this book if you don't have this
book you get this book 84 pages long
that don't only get it but get one to
give to your neighbor also good book
much of modern agronomy is focused on
feeding plants the nutrients they need
to grow for harvestable crop very little
is said about the most limited element
most needed for crop production that is
carbon we've got to have carbon we've
got to have carbon so right now you put
on your you put on your inorganic
fertilizer and you plant a plant so that
plants on welfare most the time what a
plan will do is they'll take them
through for the census they'll take in
it'll take out and you'll take the cart
of the sugar out and then the fungi will
take it and then they'll go get the
organic nitrogen so what happens when it
does this is it's got its on welfare so
it's going to use that or inorganic
nitrogen and it's gonna get lazy I mean
why wouldn't you why wouldn't you use
that if you could how many people have
you had if you had free meals given to
your pie would you have to go work so
that's exactly what the plants doing so
then when it comes time for the plant to
actually save line running out of that
inorganic fertilizer I need some more so
it goes as if since sugar out to try to
get the attention of the mycorrhizae and
the bacteria to go after and get the
organic in so instead of taking
everything to the head it's taking
everything it's got to try to go after
more fertilizer so I'm not saying we
should quit fertilizing I'm not saying I
think we need to watch what we fertilize
it may be managed or fertilizer a little
better but one thing I'm really
I'm one thing in the end I there's no
scientific deal this is just a farmer's
thought I think when you put that
fertilizer in a tight band like that I
think part of this is what helping we're
actually going off and finding it's not
being overwhelmed with that inorganic
fertilizer we soil sample with variable
rate we do our own I've been doing it
since 2000 and the main reason we do
this is because not that for most
production we're just finding out what
the fields need and I think the last
thing we on our farm right now we don't
farm for max maximum yield
we farm for maximum profit and when we
started doing that that made a lot of
difference because you know if you're
not you're gonna be going through the
180 bushel yields and you might get them
1 out of 10 years and we take an average
and so we don't do that anymore we farm
for maximum profit so you put all them
together you got a variable rate map
again same thing cost efficient
management I think you really have to do
that our feeling that's really taken us
two long ways on our farm
here's another staying of Duane's quit
putting band-aids on things when you
have something wrong instead of just
trying to find out some way to well how
am I gonna heal this or let's see I need
I need to go buy another fungicide that
will take care of this or they've got a
new herbicide and I know I gotta spray
that herbicide what you do is you go
find out what the problem is what the
issue is and it took me a while I'm a
full learner so I thought well this is
where we need to be and the reason these
are the first rotations we started with
and the reason this was is because
before the freedom to farm we had to we
had the planter fleet base the only way
we could plant wheat base is plant when
if we back on spring wheat so and so I
mean we thought we had it made well the
only thing that someone else was
thinking the cheatgrass said you know
I'm gonna figure you guys
so we went we went two times around on
this two and a half times around we
realized we had to make a change we
could either spray for cheatgrass and
keep fighting the cheatgrass or we had
to let rotations do it and and our goal
was to do it with rotation so these
aren't any big deals we just all we did
was we stayed up two years away from
there were three years away from wheat I
mean but doing this we still that's the
reason we were doing a but in the long
run what it was really doing was getting
us more diversified and helping us with
soil health and then we started cover
crops in 2006 these are a crop trades in
2017 and I know we've got forage crops
in there but one thing we'll do is we'll
go look for the markets but you can see
our high residue crop we value residue
and our dry environment we've we value
residue have to have residue if you ever
want to read something and rusty just
Charles Darwin on worms I mean you can
read for hours about what is what he
what's his thoughts were on worms
earthworms this is a field of it was
volunteer levels this fall and you know
when you the levels were sorted anyway
and and when you're full CD rates forty
pounds so it wasn't anything to leave
3040 pounds because they shattered
they're only six inches tall eight
inches tall but look at the look at the
earthworm hold there's water gonna go
down as water gonna go down it's just
got a place to go risk got a place to go
but another thing
with earthworms channels there's two and
a half times more nitrogen there's a 1/2
more carbon one and a half more times
nitrogen seven times more phosphorus at
six and a half times more potash so if
you were a plant you're in a drier
environment and you had to you said well
where am I gonna go well here's an easy
place than when I go down there I'm
going to have all that fertility I'm
gonna have all that fertility at the
earth rooms created you know the NRCS
has done a lot of work on our farm and
and along with SDSU I don't want to give
one anybody one more credit than the
other but you know the more you read the
more you realize this what's under the
soil everybody drives by and say boy
that's a nice corn crop boy that's a
nice wheat crop how many times do you
say boy let's go take a spade and go
look at that soil I mean I think we have
to do that you guys I think we have to
because soils a driving force is what's
going to happen in the future so we took
Chad and Osborne and Mike Lehman askest
told us we could bring some some soil
samples over to the lab and it was 2012
extremely dry and I said I don't think
you'll do any good because we're dry I
mean we're just terribly drying it was
middle of winter
February well February 14th guess what
else I did on Valentine's Day but anyway
so anyway and this is this is how lowly
that I know about it so I was so proud
of taking this one because look at the
rotation I mean holy buckets I mean
there wasn't any way that thing wasn't
going to be a you know as big rotation
and it was the least count so it just
kind of shows you how little we know
about what's going on under her feet but
the one thing that really helped me is
everything was still alive when you
warmed it up under a microscope it was
still alive and I just thought that
meant a lot
so mycorrhizae
Micro is a fungi if you guys ever get it
all you read everything you can about it
because that thing's helping us so much
it's been around forever but the it dumb
it moves in from legume plants that
started fertilizer is reduced destroying
the food web by tillage I mean that'll
hurt it it can access water from very
small pores in the soil bringing the
water through the plants during times
when the soil is dry when we were in
Indianapolis with dr. ray wells how to
talk and it was all the talk on what his
talk was is on the micro rise I the
ruddy structure of a mycorrhizae and
he's got pictures of my cries a poor
little gold aggregation when you get
aggregated soils that look like cottage
cheese that's the glue mona from those
is from the sugar that the mycorrhizae
takes to the center of that and then
that's what makes it as sticky and then
that's but anyway he has pictures of it
where his right and it will go right
right in the center of that and then
that's where it will take most of the
it'll go after most of my Fuhrer but I
thought it was kind of neat so we put a
we had of forage soybeans and then we
planted corn and we came back we did
this two years and one year I took it to
harvest and the other year we cut it for
silage and so what we'll do what we did
was we came back and we planted the corn
and came back about right when the corn
was spiked and plants of forage soybeans
group sevens you know and the the thing
that was really stuck out at me is so
these are the this is the corn with the
soybeans and we thought we were running
it was a drought but you see the tips of
these that corn house tipped back so
basically then forage soybeans were
feeding the nitrogen and our limited
rainfall we have to be careful with this
because then forage soybeans talk quite
a bit of moisture but it's just enough
to be kind to have to be care
Flo you know this is another thing dr.
Dave Francine we plant flocks I love
flax but it's micros a friendly flock
doesn't take any and he he would have
told you that today that's in his book
it doesn't take any phosphorous because
the mycorrhizae it goes after the
organic phosphorous if you could get him
to say it and we should ask him today
he'll tell you that sunflowers doesn't
take any phosphorous he don't recommend
any phosphorous the sunflowers and if
you would ask him is it mycorrhizae and
he probably would have said yes because
if sunflowers are very mycorrhizae
lovely in a cover crop mix there would
be sufficient link to my crazy hype in
the top four inches of a four square
yard of healthy grassland to stretch
around the world there's a lot to this I
mean you guys I really encourage you to
read about it because the more you read
about it the more you plan my carides I
plants and there's a lot of them just
realized the value of them okay now
we're gonna get into carbon we were at a
meeting in 1991 and Dwayne Beck said do
you see what I see
and he was talking about carbon it blew
over the top of my head only took me 20
years to figure it out but it's you guys
the more you the more you realize we
have to take carbon in not only take
carbon in but we have to store it 57
percent of organic matter is carbon we
have to take carbon in that's the
biggest thing about you carbon is a
driving force any time you could grow
bring it in through the plants you've
got to have carbon another thing we're
doing is we're working some native grass
and are nothing big but you know it's
kind of a rotation type deal
kind of slough area some hunting area
will put 60 acres in Lee within four or
five years to take it out again we're
getting a written structure we're
getting we're bringing that land back I
mean we're bringing it back to where it
was so I mean then we will take it back
to a crop but I just think that's really
going to help us in the long run je
Fuhrer take the world to Jai this is a
trade cronin that's Mike's son he's
going to be one of the the main owners
the farms shifting gears next year and
Kacy and Cori that's Monty's two sons
and Mike and Trager it's going to Bonnie
stepping out of the picture he's going
to retire which is you know fine but
anyway I really believe that if you have
more carbon entering your soil than
leaving your kids will probably farm
that land if you have more carbon
leaving than entering they probably will
not what he's saying is you gotta farm
for the future so we had some corn and
heavy strip of stubble in 2017
nice-looking corn old deeds we had a
Frost June 26th was it going to come
back I don't know if it was going to
come back it was really it was probably
six collar plus the thing but is our
that would have 160 acres and we lost
maybe eighty acres out of the quarter
but it was being the low ground didn't
know how to make any sense of it so we
knew we had to do something we weren't
going to leave that land alone because
it had the fertility there it wanted
something growing in it so we planted
you can't see it very well but we
planted the pearl millet because that's
what the chemical let me had kalisto on
it and brown mid we have forage sorghum
because we had cows because we had cows
here's what we ended up with I should
have done a biomass unreal unreal what
we did and to show you Ruth came up Ruth
beckoned and I said now to say Ruth
Becca should be able to say Ruth and
everybody knows her because she's up but
anyway Ruth came up and Jason and we
went out there you guys and it was it
was really something it was really felt
like this success story so what we did
as we had them so what are you gonna how
are you going to handle it now so we
went in with decided now this is our
better soils so we knew we had the
fertility there we knew organic matters
will hire there
we knew the we had still had good ground
cover you saw that on the picture so
what do you do so we cut up for silage
and you say boy you took all that stuff
off but you know that was terrible well
I understand but we had to do what we
had to do so we took this silage off but
I kept thinking look at all the root
mass we have look at the rut master we'd
have with that they've probably down
three three foot two and a half three
foot so I felt I did want to take it all
off but it's something in the way the
temperature was or the weather was the
rainfall we felt we had to so here's
another thing about if we need cover or
not so look at the temperature look at
the temperature when you start the start
evaporating 85 percent of the moisture
loss through evaporation transpiration
at 95 degrees so what happens on bare
soils you know if you guys ever done
much of this it doesn't take very much
to go over the thermometer and get a
hundred and hundred and ten degrees soil
on bare soil so this is just one of them
things and this isn't my pictures the
NRCS my thermometers sideways and it's
hard to take a picture but look at the
difference same day same place these
came from Jay Fuhrer we have to have
that soil Armen
we have to have that soil covered so
here's where organic matter
when we started taking off I mean so
it's building and we felt good about it
and that we're no-tilling and you know
you feel you know we're going in the
right direction because if we would not
have I don't know where we would have
been because when you the microbes are
going to eat something and they're going
to eat organic matter if they don't have
anything any carbon that you brought in
so they're going to eat something so
this is 10% it's where we used to be we
let a lot of places in the United States
for less than two what do you think that
grant was telling his grandson I'm sorry
when we were in Indiana with the buffett
people we had people from the thumb of
Michigan we had from the Boot Hill
Missouri from Nebraska to Indiana to
Iowa and a lot of guys you talk about
organic wagon they didn't want to really
talk about organic matter but when they
did talk that their lot of members in
the one and a half two twos the two and
a halves
they're trying to do it all with they're
getting in to cover crops now that's
what they should but because they've got
to get carbon back to make organic
matter they're trying to do with the
inorganic nutrients so this is what
we've done on our farm and so what I did
was I took of that grass was planted in
the 30s it was planted back in the 30s
so I took a soil sample of it I should
have gone to native but so it was five
point one an average land in 2008 was
2.8 and we have a lot of land in the
fours right now what I'm going to say
about cover crops anytime you get a
cover crop going on your field but I
mean I'm talking a pretty active cover
crop where everything's really Perkin
well I think you know I used to say if
you could gain a tenth of a percent a
year you're doing well and I think you
could get the two tenths or maybe even
three tenths here by uses of the cover
crop
I think cover crop is just going to
jumpstart that soil one thing too is and
Jay talked about
is when you plant covers don't be
disappointed after the first year
because he explains it kind of like a
soybean where the second year soybeans
always better than the first year
natively and he says it's just something
about it because you plan to cover on
that stubble it's just kind of a shock
to this house stuff that's never had
before but it's always better the second
time around so while I'm really saying
to you guys it's just this this ain't
just a one or two year deal we just got
to have to keep working on this benefits
twenty to thirty pounds of nitrogen
sulfur phosphorus what I would pay
attention to the most is your organic
matter water holding capacity and our
dryer environment that's tremendously
important if I can hold another 1/2 or
3/4 inch of water that's going to get me
through that tough time time and time
again it shows that mineralization this
fall we really you know we just
everybody said boy I can't believe we've
got that much nitrogen well all it is is
is the microbes are really working and
they're working on your organic matter
and whatever whatever but the more
organic matter you have the more
mineralization you're gonna have this is
our word organic matter what's going now
and that's uh I feel good about that I
just hope we can keep the one thing
about it is we're not going backwards I
do not take credit for organic matter in
a soil test they will not 1% of organic
matter is like one point one trillion
waters a gallon per day over Niagara
Falls one percent over the United States
that's how much water that 1% of organic
matter could hold it's our savings
account when we fertilize for one
hundred and forty and you can have a
good moisture and get 160 how do you get
that you get it from your organic matter
but Dave Francine says just like Connie
and he just came out with this
on his corn deal if you have 6% organic
matter over he'll credit he won't credit
until you get 60% he sees the value of
organic matter so like when he talks
about fertilizing wheat which I'm not
saying I don't I'm a farmer I don't have
I don't have enough knowledge or
education disagree with dr. Francine but
I don't I don't really believe that
because what he's saying he's going to
fertilize for two bushel wheat and if he
gets rain the organic matter is gonna
kick in the only thing is it's what if
you don't have five percent organic
matter what if you're two and a half and
so I think I think I I really think
that's critical that you that's why we
won't use any organic matter credit we
do what we don't we don't use it as
credit when we do use organic matter
this is on the Internet $600 six hundred
eighty dollars for one percent of
organic matter and I just put some of
our own numbers in and you still there's
really still quite a value to 1% of
organic matter if you own your land if
you own your own land why aren't you
doing that why aren't you trying to get
more organic matter everybody says I'm
too hot to drive whatever whatever but
optimum management and add an external
carbon stores anytime you can anytime
you can cover crops you guys
this is our first cover crop Dwayne you
know he was going he was trying to get
someone to try cover crops and he got me
kind of cornered and so we did it the
only thing is is we come off a really
dry year we had thirteen point seven
inches of moisture but it was really a
low carbon to only a twenty to one
carbon and and I was worried about it
and he was worried about it enough he
called one day and he said when you're
gonna start combining that and I said
well we're probably gonna be doing it
Tuesday and Tuesday morning he pulled in
and he rolled with me so he was as
nervous as I was but it turned out
pretty good for his we ended up with
good moisture in 2007 but it turned out
for us so another question so we're
gonna plant cover crops there's not
enough people a lot of people what
they'll do is though and I'm not I think
there's a tremendous lot of good seed
sales when I I hope I don't offend
anybody but when you walk up your seed
salesman you say this is what I want to
do I want to graze it I want to increase
organic matter you know and whatever you
want to do you want to use up the excess
moisture whatever you want to do you
have them goals and usually what I do
when I sit down to make my my cover crop
plans I have three things in mind if
it's grazing organic matter would it be
one two three I always have my first one
but don't just go up there and say I
need a cover crop they can help you they
know what you want but you let them know
what you want
this is from the NRCS jason miller and
jeff Hemmings we made this and it's a
good chart and and what I usually do
let's just take flocks for instance so
you know it's highly my karai's I it's
good you know an intelligent it's very
organic matter carbonate nitrogen ratio
high but so one thing too is you look at
the seeding rate full seeding rate
twenty pounds so when I make a cover
crop mix if I got five things and I
wonder so I got five things that we like
I want so I'll do twenty percent of each
one so right now that'd be four pounds
of flax and that's how I build my cover
crop mix so do a percentage if you feel
really good about it if you've got
enough moisture I sometimes go to 115 to
120 percent that's that's who I I'm not
saying this the right ways just the way
I do it
another thing Chris mentioned this this
is on the Google cover crop chart ARS
and you can go and they'll tell you
anything you want to know about any
cover crop the carbon and nitrogen ratio
everything salt-tolerant good website
one thing I found in the Sarah book and
I started doing this because when we
plant sorghum Sudan grass we always
plant Piper's today on grass I never
plant one thing alone
Piper's today on grass and probably like
either a white a white wonder of a
German millet because I never want
anything alone I think that everybody
gets along better when there's something
else there then another thing about that
millet is it keeps the windrow fluffy
and but the one thing that really just
look at that so a few money seen this
six inch stub will look how much deeper
the rust go more root mass more it takes
in more carbon the more benefit that's
taught soil microbes I mean if a guy has
cattle I mean I think this is a win-win
carbon-to-nitrogen ratio so you know one
time Dwayne was up and I was talking
about all our high carbon crops at all
this double we had and and he made the
comment to me he said but you have to
learn to manage that that's a high
management and that I thought well you
know anybody could but it is I mean is 8
inches of stubble it's ok but is it too
much so you just have to kind of realize
what you want to do with your cover crop
or with your soil cover with your carbon
but one thing you have to be awful
careful that you don't use it up and you
leave some right now like on our littles
and peas where a lot of guys will go on
corn stalks I'll plant them on some on
sprinkly stubble okay so I got spring
wheat stubble then lentils and then I'll
and then I'll come back to corn corn or
winter wheat for one thing is the weed
control
if I've got a cheatgrass issue downy
Brome issue behind the spring wheat the
lentils I can take anything out I want
as far as grass is concerned and then I
can come back to one of wheat the next
year and then corn so I just take a
break I don't have any set rotations and
I don't know if that's right or wrong
it's just something that works for us
carbon nitrogen ratio so like that one
we said was right here on that first
cover crop ideal is right here and I
don't know on our where soil czar so
active with the mature soil so I like to
be a little higher than that and we
started working covers into our pivots
covers and rotations because I thought
this is really an important thing as we
were the corn bean guys were kind of
caught up in that and that was the best
thing we ever did was get was get rid of
that corn bean corn bean corn bean we
got rid of our white mold issue I mean
you talk about a win-win situation so we
plan a lot of different crops down there
you know and I've heard the comment
today how do you make money on wheat how
do you make money on oats you plan a
cover behind them
you put your cattle on there so we had a
we had a pivot it was filled peas and we
planned two full season cover in 2016
and the boys always passed you in so
what they'll do is they'll take the know
that they'll along the river they'll
take the cows on one side of the fence
and the calves on the other the calves
will stay next to the river where they
used to drink and out of and then
they'll then they'll just leave them
like that well this year what they did
so it was a we planted a 10-way mix
that's snow in the air these are the
calves so what they did is they put the
pears in and then after about seven days
they took the cows out and the calves
didn't have any idea of what happened
they just they were so satisfied they
didn't care whatever but the one thing
that really noticeable about that
usually bring the cows home about the
fifteenth the septic Absalom about the
15th of September and this year we that
year they didn't have to because this is
like the seventh of November and them
calves are still there and they're still
doing good there's no dust there's
there's plenty of grazing so I that was
really a and we're gonna try to copy
that again we got two pivots kind of set
up for that purpose this coming year so
this is a we planted the corn in 2017
and this is a heavy Gumble circle heavy
heavy soil when I broke them the circles
back in 70 I don't know a 77 or 78 with
the disc the there was two circles
side-by-side 140-acre circle and this
circle was virgin sod the homesteaders
knew enough not to farm this so we
always struggle with raising the crop
always struggle so then we got into
no-till and we really helped yourselves
this is the second time this fields had
covers on it and this respondent it's
getting so we can manage it now we're
getting good yields we had to 20-plus on
it this year but this is something I'd
like to be able to do it again and I
don't know how but this is the volunteer
come
from the year before the cattle stomped
the oats and the radishes and turnips in
five minutes kale have to hustle but
they but it really is a win-win
situation for the cattle so we started
in 2016 I said well let's I think we can
make more money raising the full season
Covercraft of what we can plant wheat
and I so we my goal was is so we planted
June 6 and the tests double really
diversified mix so you can see the one
thing I really focused on is our micro
rise I everything I put in there how to
had a reason we put it in there I wanted
to 32 to 1 racial carbon and nitrogen so
we'll just follow that through so this
is our this is a quarter section we left
some in free strips I put a threeway in
just to see why if the 3 would be rather
than a 12 way put 50 pounds the end up
planning and you know I didn't know if I
should really do that or not and then je
Fuhrer said he didn't think a guy should
and then this is where it cross Fitz's
went when we fed during the wintertime
so that we saw their different paddocks
June 29th you can see the end free
strips so full season
that's a hard picture to see but I loved
kale kale the last way into the winter
so here's what we what happened and so
this is what we ended up with with most
of field 80 200 pounds of biomass we're
down to 25 to 1 carbon nitrogen ratio
but you know 11 percent protein you can
see that how much more we gained from
with the no end don't know in the
earlier we had 7600 but it really fell
off because the young succulent plants
gave out with the cold weather so this
is just the relative feed value so what
I did is is I said okay let's find out
what we're gonna do here so I wanted to
know I knew how much it cost us I knew
what I wanted to say
we went ahead and I tracked all the the
temperatures of what the cattle should
eat there's a 650 had eaten there but
one thing I didn't really count on we
had a lot of snow and then we had we got
really cold and sold in the long run we
had to feed if we fed 1/4 of our feeding
through the wagon was it really a win it
was still a win did we make as much
money as we thought we did
no we didn't but the big it really
showed up this year coming off that full
season cover we wintered 150 head of
deer and kind of waiting for the game
fish and parks to pay us for that one
but I guess we'll wait a while so Jason
and Ruth and Hosea and Dwayne set up a
plot plan and this is kind of a so this
is 28% and then the rest of this is
seated this way with their planning so
here's what we come up with her they
came up with I'm just here for the I
could say I get it but they're all here
so I better not but one thing I really
thought was so right now you take the
one with the one with the no side side
band in was 181 bushel no side band in
was 149 beside with more nitrogen it was
less so we put the stream bar on the 2nd
of May 46 degrees temperature humidity
74% but it was 7 days before we had a
quarter inch of rain was out the reason
I used stream bars so I didn't want to
spread it out I wanted to have a stream
bar come down so the furiousness header
was flowing and uh breaking it down so I
mean it just really showed us a lot of
things and you'll talk to Jason
Dwayne Routh or anybody and use your
yields or 10 to 12 percent more when you
hand harvested these were hand harvested
so they're usually more they were dried
down to 8 percent this is official as
you could get
it's just like we the morning
the more protein but look at here so
everybody says boy I gotta like it's not
such a thing it's put too much nitrogen
on look what it did 100 180 pounds of
nitrogen 176 bushel that's 60 pounds of
nitrogen look what it cost it's 9 bushel
11 bushel but so anything and the thing
of it is on this field we're gonna go
back on that same spot and they're gonna
do that same thing they're gonna
replicate the same exact spot everything
is going to be the same we're gonna have
three or four of these trials around the
farm we have to find out if we should be
using one or one point - everybody's
going to be different we're not going to
use one point - but we have to find out
if we can use in our environment with
our system we got to find out if we can
use a eight tenths of a pound or nine
tenths of a pound so this is a the one
thing this we did a strip with the
starter different rates have started but
one thing I want you to notice so this
was soil sampled in the spring before we
planted corn and you'll see this time
and time again I mean you know a lot of
people talk about it after cover after
cover later in the year you'll get a
spike in your phosphorous and this here
might have been a fluke the only thing
is that a lot where they see at four
point four then three point eight so I
mean at least there's an increase I'm
going to get hollered out again here so
this is what this is basically how our
plots turned out so there wasn't there
wasn't any significant difference sent
it to ward lab there's 388 pounds of
organic phosphorus in that soil the
micro rise I went and looked after the
wind got that organic phosphorous this
test right here is a twelve dollar and
fifty cent test award lab if you want to
find out your total phosphorous in the
field so full season grazing we're going
to do the same thing the only thing is
I'm going to maybe try to increase the
the carbon and nitrogen ratio it's going
to be a dry so we soil sample
excuse me with planet covers and a lot
of talk was his covers worth negative so
we had this field side-by-side there
this did not have covered they were just
sixteen rows apart and so we went in so
I soil sampled it in the in in November
16 before the coroner is nine pounds
where there wasn't cover there's 38
pounds so I came back and we soiled
sampler after corn harvest and we had 89
pounds and here we had 38 so I gave it
back to us it just didn't give it back
to us in time for the the cattle I soil
I fertilize this accordingly so this is
a our cover crop mix it's kind of a
there's a reason in that by I went to
that mix but this is what I the so we
ended up with a no cover was 160 with
cover is 156 so you take all it during
that cost you $26 when I credited
ourselves back to the residual end and
all I'm saying is you can't say anything
off the side by side this should even be
shown you've got to be replicated you
got to be replicated three times value
of it this is what our corn you know
this is these are three years these are
three years all I'm trying to say is I
know the corn varieties gets part of
that but look at their 1994 19.5 2016
18.8 are we going in the right direction
this is what its kind of scares me a
little bit look at the amount of grass
that came out in powder county look at
the amount of beans over 2006 to 2017
corn went up look at the winter wheat in
the winter if he's going to be less when
if we going to be down there around
12,000 this year the teal Don beans is
38 bushel the beans are gonna be way
over here so then we'll look at Davidson
County look how much you guys took away
from pasture increased soybeans some
corn some you eavesdropping
corne retires 9 inches moisture
vegetative growth adds 10 bushel for
each additional inch so a yield goal 140
pounds how can you do that how can you
reach that and it's organic matter the
use of a savings account
58% of organic matters carbon low
disturbance no-till there's a lot of
reasons we need to learn to farm to the
maximum profit not the maximum yield let
the soil help you with that you know a
great deal of carbon to once restored
the soil null storing the atmosphere and
it's there you guys all we have to do is
learn to get it and and we definitely
need to return the carbon back to humans
this is really makes you feel good
because right here look at the youth on
our farm and everybody says everybody
said boy you guys got a lot of people on
the farm well three of these aren't ours
but you've got a lot of people on the
farm and but everybody's get along fine
we're making it work and we're not real
big but we're making it work and just
because we're we're trying to make the
we're taking care of the soil and the
soils taking care of us you know this is
something that change happens when the
pain of staying the same is greater than
the pain of change just think about that
I feel we should do everything we can to
make this a better world and why who
cares and just this picture is going to
tell the story I'm not going to say
anything about it I don't think we have
a choice okay thank you guys sorry I
sorry